SILICONE VALLEY.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
EKE
EK
>> ♪ ♪
>> Bret: IN TONIGHT'S WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO SEGMENT, THE EFFORT
TO EXPAND EXPLORE
TO EXPAND EXPLOAT
TO EXPAND EXPLOATIO
TO EXPAND EXPLOATION
TO EXPAND EXPLOATION F
TO EXPAND EXPLOATION FOR
TO EXPAND EXPLOATION FOR O
TO EXPAND EXPLOATION FOR OIL
AND GAS IN THE U.S.
NOW AMERICA APPEARS TO BE ON A
PATH OF ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
THAT'S A TOP SPOT AMONG WORLD
OIL PRODUCERS.
CHRISTIAN FISHERS TELLS US WHERE
WE ARE AND WHERE WE MAY BE
GOING.
>> WE NEED AN AMERICAN FIRST
ENERGY PLAN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN A
FRIEND OF FOSSIL FUELS SINCE THE
FIRST DAY OF HIS CAMPAIGN FOR A
PIPELINE.
OVER A YEAR INTO THE JOB A NEW
STUDY SHOWS THE U.S. IS ON TRACK
TO BE THE WORLD'S LARGEST OIL
PRODUCER BY 2023 THANKS TO THE
BLOOMING U.S. INDUSTRY AND
RECORD SETTING FOOD PRODUCTION,
THE HIGHEST IN 50 YEARS AND CUTS
IN SUPPLY FROM CURRENT LEADERS
LIKE SAUDI ARABIA AND RUSSIA.
IT WILL TAKE AT LEAST THAT LONG
BEFORE THE PIPELINE IS
OPERATIONAL.
ANY DRILLING LEASES ARE
APPROVED.
THE PIPELINE WAS PLAGUED BY
LAWSUITS FROM LAND OWNERS AND
ENVIRONMENTALISTS.
THE COMPANY INTENDS TO START
CONSTRUCTION NEXT YEAR.
IT SAYS IT HASN'T MADE A FINAL
DECISION TO BUILD IT.
AS FOR OFF SCORE DRILLING
NJANUARY, THE INTERIOR SECRETARY
ANNOUNCED A PLAN TO OPEN ALL
U.S. WATERS TO OFF-SHORE OIL
DRILLING IN 5 YEARS.
THAT WAS MET WITH WIDESPREAD
BIPARTISAN OPPOSITION ON THE
ATLANTIC AND PACIFIC COASTS.
5 DAYS LATER AFTER MEETING WITH
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
THE SECRETARY PULLED IT OFF THE
TABLE.
SAYING FLORIDA IS UNIQUE AND
THEY RELY ON TOURISM.
THAT PROMPTED GOVERNOR'S TO SAY
WE ARE UNIQUE TOO.
THE SECRETARY SAID THEY SHOULD
REOF RECEIVE AN EXEMPTION.
>> OFF WASHINGTON AND CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE NO KNOWN RESOURCES OF
ANY WEIGHT.
>> THE GOVERNOR'S OF ONLY 2
STATE SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT'S
PLAN.
ALASKA AND MAINE.